la quatrième circonscription de saône et
loire est souvent appelée la
circonscription de la bresse c'est à la
fois vrai et faux
car on y trouve également le tournugeois
le val de saône et chalon nord ce qui
représente 115 1466 habitants c'est
ainsi la circonscription la plus peuplée
du département
c'est ici qu'un certain arnaud
montebourg a été élu jusqu'en 2012 avant
qu'il ne passe le flambeau à cécile une
paire meilleur pour la députée sortante
le challenge est important
elle mène une campagne mêlant meeting et
porte à porte afin de défendre son bilan
mais sur ces plaquettes on ne retrouve
plus le locaux socialistes
non il n'ya pas le logo ps parce que si
vous voulez je suis une femme de gauche
libre pas du tout attachés à un parti je
ne suis jamais allé chercher mes valeurs
dans un parti c'est moi qui suis venu
avec mes valeurs et j'ai été retenu par
partie à partir de là tout s'oublie
est ce que je veux c'est l'intérêt
général depuis 2002 je m'attache je
m'attache à mettre l'intérêt général au
coeur de mon travail
donc vous voyez que c'était en marche
bien avant en marche
justement du côté d' en marche la
situation était chaotique
aucun militant du mouvement n'a été
investi lors de la première vague et
c'est sur internet que les marcheurs ont
appris le nom de leur candidat dans la
circonscription
catherine gabrel maire de royer elle
bénéficie de l'accord national avec le
moderne
j'avoue que j'avais même jamais réfléchi
aux législatives parce que ça me
paraissait énorme quoi et du coup
pourquoi pas parce que c'est une
expérience enrichissante ça me plaît
donc oui et puis après j'ai attendu un
bon moment avant qu'on me rappelle donc
je suppose qu'à eu des tractations des
choses dégénèrent non encarté au modem
catherine gabrel au visage de prendre sa
carte à la république en marche et
s'associe une militante de ce mouvement
pour la campagne
du côté des républicains de lui dit le
candidat officiel s'appelle stéphane
grout il a 36 ans il est artisan et
maire de la commune dorment ses axes de
campagne sont la valeur travail la
proximité et le renouvellement de la
classe politique
mais ces messages pourraient être
brouillées vis-à-vis des électeurs de
droite car il doit faire face à une
candidature dissidente
j'ai beaucoup de soutien de collègues
maires de conseillers départementaux
d'amis qui sont derrière moi qu'ils
estiment aussi qu un vent de renouveau
est important alors voilà je respecte
l'adversaire et je répète le meilleur
gagne et le grain de sable dans la
campagne à droite s'appelle eric michoux
chefs d'entreprise et maire d'epervans
il veut mettre en avant son expérience
non non non non non je ne suis pas un
candidat dissident
je suis un candidat légitime
aujourd'hui si vous regardez le nombre
de soutiens politiques que j'ai ya aucun
candidat qu'elle est soutien politique
que j'ai ça soit le sénateur emorine et
le nombre de conseillers départementaux
et vice président du conseil
départemental
mais la guerre des droites
bénéficiera-t-elle au front national
car lors de l'élection présidentielle le
parti de marine le pen est arrivé en
tête au premier tour dans la
circonscription
un score sur lequel maxime thibeault
compte bien capitaliser
ainsi ils quittent debout la france pour
se présenter sous l'étiquette frontiste
je suis la vraie opposition à macron une
position constructive vers l'avenir
parce que l'idée c'est quand même de
défendre l'indépendance de la france la
liberté des français et l'avenir de nos
enfants faut construire une belle europe
des projets il faut reprendre le pouvoir
sur tout ses intérêts financiers et
c'est ce que je veux incarner aux côtés
de florian philippot
au final avec deux candidats à droite
une extrême droite importante et
l'émergence du mouvement marche
il est difficile d'établir des
pronostics une triangulaire n'est
d'ailleurs pas à exclure pour la députée
sortante
les autres candidats et candidates dans
cette 4e circonscription fabienne
delorme pour l eau sandrine bernadat
pour le parti communiste michel chambon
pour la france a soumises marie claude
collin cordier pour europe écologie joël
jallet pour la wii christiane lemière
pour debout la france et guillaume
ferrand pour l'upm douze candidats et
candidates au total dans cette
circonscription